[Musique]
sois mon homme tu l'as fait tu as explosé partout
dans les nouvelles
es-tu seul Je veux juste l'argent tu
as la
puce bien la remettre en marche pourquoi n'irais-
tu pas aux toilettes nous laver nous allons
être avec toi dans une minute
aha allez mec ton cou c'est un gâchis
initiant la destination du mode combat d'
accord dans les chiennes annoncées
nous sommes riches oh nous allons à la
charité des ligues majeures
oh oh d'accord allez à la clinique maintenant ses toilettes
état critique
lancement hé  hey pense juste à toutes les
bonnes conneries qu'on va avoir hein oh désolé
ton
ami psychopathe est-ce que nous n'avions pas besoin de toute
cette attention de [ __ ] de [ __ ] [ __ ]